là monsieur bonsoir le tour de france
commence mal à l'arrivée à armentières
cet après midi c'est le sprint final les
coureurs se déporte sur la droite de la
route vers les barrières de sécurité
c'est la chute
plusieurs coureurs percuté un policier
qui prenait une photo de coureurs ont
été sérieusement blessé le belge denis
seine et le français jalabert qui était
le meilleur français de ce tout le récit
complet des événements
thierry clopeau voici le vélo de laurent
jalabert ou tout du moins ce qu'il en
reste après le choc
à près de 70 km heure dix secondes plus
tôt c'est le sprint
un policier imprudent décalé par rapport
à la barrière qui prend une photo le
landais nelly scène le frappe alors de
plein fouet
derrière ces jalabert tueur plus aussi
pleine phase l'agent des forces de
l'ordre est un panneau publicitaire
stupéfaction dans le public
les deux coureurs et le policier assez
sérieusement blessé sont immédiatement
secouru par les médecins du tour premier
diagnostic
le policier souffre d'un enfoncement du
thorax laurent jalabert ensemble à
plusieurs lésions à la mâchoire et des
fractures aux incisives
quant à nelly scène traumatisme crânien
il est transporté comme les deux autres
à l'hôpital d'armentières
puis sur le chu de lille pour examen au
scanner mais d'ores et déjà les deux
coureurs sont déclarés inaptes à
poursuivre le tour la question que tout
le monde se pose ce soir est ce une
faute d'organisation ou une erreur
humaine 50 mètres de l'arrivée un
politique qui est au milieu de la route
parce qu'elle a décollé la photographie
sur la ligne
pour la direction du tour il y a bien eu
faute du policier tentative
d'explication c'est donc une espèce de
d'erreur humaine de la part de sept
jaunes police on peut ne pas incriminer
totalement dans la mesure où ces agents
de police locaux que nous recevons
chaque jour sont différents qu'ils ne
connaissent pas les usages du tour de
france les risques du tour de france
mais enfin n'oubliez pas que le peloton
traverse villes les villages à parfois
plus de 60 kilomètres heure les voitures
du tour à 100 km heure alors surtout
rester derrière les barrières c'est
votre sécurité et la sécurité des
coureurs qui en dépend il faut que ce
tour parce qu'une fête